hey guys I'm Dave Rubin and this is the
all-new Reuben report we're in a great
new studio with an awesome new set and a
fantastic new crew it's been a long
journey for me to get here from
interning at the Daily Show in 1999 to
14 years of stand-up comedy in New York
City to Sirius XM to the Young Turks to
my new home here at aura TV we're gonna
be rounding out the political and
current events coverage alongside two
huge influences of mine broadcasting
legend Larry King and free speech beacon
Jesse Ventura as many of you know over
the last few months I've been really
disappointed by people supposedly on my
team the left on issues of political
correctness and free speech toss in the
social justice warriors and our lap dog
media and debate and I mean true debate
gets totally tossed out the window to me
there is literally nothing more
important in a democracy than free
speech and debate we should debate
everything we should talk about
everything we should engage in ideas
that we aren't comfortable with and we
should let the best ideas win that's how
a healthy society based on rational
ideas and a secular government should
work but too often these days it simply
isn't what's happening and while the far
right in this country went off the deep
end a while ago what I've really been
affected by is seeing my side the people
on the Left cherry-picking facts
stifling debate and labeling everyone
they disagree with the racist bigot a
homophobe or worse
these aren't liberal principles much
less are they the ideals our founders
intended for us to use when they started
this country by the way I know I'm not
the only one feeling this as I've
started talking more and more about
political correctness free speech and
true liberal values like women's rights
gay rights and human rights around the
world I've seen a huge amount of people
waking up alongside of me I see it in
the YouTube comments I see it on Twitter
on Facebook and everywhere else there's
been an awakening of the same majority
and if I can use my voice to be any part
of that then that's why I'm here so with
that in mind I want to set a couple
ground rules for how we're gonna do this
show rule number one I promise you that
beyond anything else I will not
blatantly lie to you one of our biggest
problems these days is nobody knows who
to trust anymore we have politicians who
lie endlessly and a mainstream media
that helps them do it either by asking
the wrong questions or not asking any
questions at all then we have an online
media that is fact-check by nobody thus
left to its own devices I
do my best to get information to you in
an honest way I will get things wrong
sometimes but it won't be intentional
and that brings me to number two please
fact check me if you hear me say saying
that you think is factually unsound or
patently wrong call me out on it tweet
at me respond in the youtube comments or
email me I'll discuss them with the team
and we'll address the ones that should
be addressed and we'll even credit you
for it rule number three I won't talk
about people's personal lives unless
they're hypocritical politicians it
seems to me we've gotten in a really bad
habit of thinking that everyone's
business is our business and nobody has
a right to privacy that's just not going
to be what we do here I don't care what
people do in their bedroom or in their
personal life as long as it isn't a
politician voting one way and doing
something else privately just because
someone hacks into someone's email or
there are naked pictures of some
celebrity doesn't mean we have to feed
this monster rule number four I won't be
a partisan hack one of the worst things
on cable news is that they think debate
is taking a Republican operative and a
Democratic strategist sitting them
across from each other and letting them
go at it that is not debate that's just
dribble do you know how many former
White House officials and party leaders
work for the cable news channels I don't
know either
but yeah it's a lot yes I tend to agree
more with people on the left but I'm not
in this for the Democrats I think there
is sold out and as corrupt as the
Republicans and I'm gonna call them both
out for it rule number five I will
consistently stand for liberal values
and I won't demonize everyone who
disagrees with me I believe in free
speech I want minorities to be treated
equally I want women to be treated
equally I want gays to be treated Lee I
want everybody to be treated equally and
these are the principles that I will
always defend and please note there that
I said equally I don't think anyone
deserves special treatment or special
favors and then when we're all equal we
can treat everyone as crappy as they
treat us you know the American Dream
rule number six we're gonna talk about
big ideas here we're so bogged down in
attacking people that we rarely talk
about why we were talking about them at
all I want to talk about what the role
of government should be what kind of
foreign policy we should have ethical
debates about abortion and stem-cell
research not about the small-minded
people who are often driving the
conversations there's gonna be a tough
one because sometimes these people have
to be addressed but I'll try to do it
sparingly and for good reason rule
number seven I promise to keep reading
as many of your tweets comments and
messages as humanly possible I want this
to be a conversation not just me talking
at you when you should know that I
struggle reading any
that's over 140 characters rule number
eight I won't fake outrage for clicks
and views there's enough ranting and
raving on TV and online and if that's
what you're looking for look elsewhere
rule number nine I'm gonna be relating
things back to Star Wars often usually
in a pretty coherent way but that might
require you to do some homework and if a
Star Wars reference goes over your head
you can't just try to figure it out you
have to actually do it in the words of
Yoda try not do or do not there is no
try and rule number 10 I will not always
live up to these rules but I will try I
mean do the best I can